[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
their remains still the third side the
relation to absolute being of
consciousness as action this action is
the setting aside of the particularity
of the individual or the natural mode of
its being for self whence proceeds at
certainty of being pure self
consciousness of being in accordance
with its action that is as an
independent individual one with absolute
being since an action purposiveness and
end are distinguished and pure insight
in relation to this action equally
adopts a negative attitude and isn't as
in the other moments denies its own self
it must
as regards purposiveness exhibit itself
as lacking in intelligence since insight
United with intention that is the
harmony of ended means appears to it as
an other or rather as the opposite of
insight as regards the end itself
however it has to make badness enjoyment
and possession its end and so prove
itself to be the impure assigned of
intention since pure intention qua other
is equally impure intention
paragraph 555 is short but there's a lot
going on here Hegel's making a important
transition from the second moment which
was one of the relations to absolute
consciousness that of knowledge after
talking about the the first thing which
is Faith's
grasp on on absolute being as such how
faith pictures absolute being to itself
then how faith knows absolute being now
he's talking about action the
comportment of the believer to the
object of faith absolute being whether
that is understood in terms of the
divine or in terms of as we've seen
already the religious community so he
tells us there remains the third side
right the the the relation of the
absolute being of consciousness as
action and the word there is ton we've
seen this many times before this came up
a lot in the consciousness or in the
reasons section I mean it did come up to
some degree in the consciousness and
self consciousness but really in the
reason section where we had a lot of
exploration of this once we got past the
first part of reason and then it came up
again in the spirit section earlier on
we're constantly seeing this theme of
it's not enough to talk just about
thought but thought itself must
culminate in action so what are the
components of action how does the action
articulate itself well he tells us
action is the setting aside of the
particularity of the individual in this
case so you know this is talking about
action by the person who really is a
believer not somebody who's just using
belief to get you know their own private
ends perhaps to get power or money or
something like that but somebody who is
in a relationship of faith or belief
globba they set aside their own he says
particularity or the natural
of its being for self the natural motive
it's being for self that we saw
discussed in the entire culture section
right this was what the ignoble
consciousness focused on so we're seeing
the noble consciousness kind of rearing
its head again
so he says whence proceeds at certainty
of being pure self-consciousness of
being in accordance with its action that
is as an independent individual one with
absolute being so right now we're we've
lost that sense of being one with
absolute being by just you know making
oneself the absolute being and the
question is well how do we relate
ourselves to this this absolute being
through what it is that we're doing
through our action we might want to
remind ourselves about the the forms of
action that Hegel has been talking about
in this section and in previous sections
the religious comportment what what are
religious actions that's something we
should think about not just in terms of
say prayer but in terms of service
devotion sacrifice right and Hegel goes
on to make a very important distinction
here he says in action two things that
are very closely connected
linguistically and intentionally are
being distinguished from each other
namely at the end and purposiveness now
in German these are a little bit closer
right we have Zach the end or the goal
where you can say purpose if you want
what it is that you're attempting to
achieve what is it you're attending
intending and then purposiveness Zach
Messi kite how you tailor the action
itself to attain that sort of end when
we talk about an action being purposive
we mean that there is some sort of point
to it that would be another way to
translate sveck right the point of the
action when Aristotle begins the
Nicomachean ethics by saying every
choice every you know mode of inquiry
every action all these sorts of things
they all have a
a Telos that's the same sort of idea so
we have the the the end the goal and
then we have how we structure the action
so as to attain that what it is you
might say that the end does to condition
the action so he says these can be
distinguished and then he says pure
insight in relation to this action whose
action the action of faith adopts a
negative attitude right he says as in
the other moments it denies its own self
it must as regards purposiveness exhibit
itself as lacking in intelligence that's
a strange thing for Hegel to say about
insight isn't it
insight lacks in intelligence why would
insight be lacking in intelligence well
it's not actually grasping what what
faith is doing he says it denies its own
self and it must as regards
purposiveness exhibit itself as lacking
intelligence why because insight United
with intention Isaac and on zicht all
right what is it
the harmony of means and ends what which
is what purposiveness and an end action
is the means the end is the the purpose
there the point all right it's denying
to faith what it would Accord to itself
he says this harmony of ends and means
appears to it as an other or is the
opposite of insight now notice what else
he says about this as regards the end
itself it has to make badness enjoyment
and possession its end what it what is
the end of the religious person badness
enjoyment possession its end and so
prove itself to be the impurity of
intention since pure intention qua other
is equally into your intention what are
we talking about here
again the fundamental misunderstanding
of what the believer is doing the
sincere believer the genuine believer
not the you know person who's just
trying to make a buck or the person
who's completely superstitious in sight
is not able to understand this insight
is not able to make sense in a human way
of the human action that is somehow
connecting the the believer to what is
believed it
accordingly we see that as regards
purposiveness enlightenment finds it
foolish when the believer gives himself
the superior consciousness of not being
in bondage to natural enjoyment and
pleasure by actually denying himself
natural enjoyment and pleasure and
demonstrating by his actions that his
contempt for them is no lie but is
genuine
similarly enlightenment finds it foolish
that the individual absolves itself of
its quality of being absolutely
individual excluding all others and of
possessing property of its own by itself
giving up its property for thereby it
shows in truth that it is not in earnest
with this isolation of itself but is
raised above the natural necessity of
isolating itself and in this absolute
isolation of being for self denying that
others are the same as itself pure
insight finds both to be of no purpose
as well as wrong the purpose of showing
oneself to be free of pleasure and
possession is not served by denying
oneself pleasure and giving away a
possession in the opposite case
therefore it will declare them the man
of fool who in order to eat has recourse
to actually eating insight also finds it
wrong to deny oneself a meal and to give
away butter and eggs not for money nor
butter money for butter and eggs but
simply to give them away without
receiving anything in return it declares
a meal or the possession of things of
that sort to be an end in itself and
hence in fact declares itself to be a
very impure intention which treats such
enjoyment and possession as something
wholly essential again it also affirms
as a pure intention the necessity of
rising above natural existence above a
quiz ative 'no cebause the means of
existence only it finds it foolish and
wrong that this elevation should be
demonstrated by deeds in other words
this pure insight is in truth a
deception which pains and demands and
inner elevation but declares that it is
superfluous foolish and even wrong to be
in earnest about it to put this
elevation into actual practice and
demonstrate its truth pure insight thus
denies itself both as pure insight for a
denies directly purpose of action and as
pure intention for
denies the intention of proving itself
read from the ends of a separate
individual existence
in paragraph 556 we find Hegel taking up
the same line of criticism against
insight and the Enlightenment which is
being turned against the religious
believer now deepening the the
examination of action what is it that
the action of the religious believer
consists in what is it trying to attain
what is its end its vak and why is the
the religious believer acting and the
way that they do with the kind of
purposiveness Zak messy tight tailoring
the means of action what they do to the
ends so Hegel is going to tell us that
as regards purposiveness enlightenment
is telling the believer that they're a
fool they're they're behaving foolishly
not by the end that they have but by the
means that they select the purposiveness
the Beck Messi kite of their action
what is he criticizing the the person of
the Enlightenment he's saying you're
giving things up that you shouldn't give
up why shouldn't you give them up what
what are they first of all Hegel tells
us there are going to be enjoyment
pleasure and property these are things
of if not necessarily the body certainly
of the world and the religious believer
is willing to sacrifice these to say
these don't count as much and I need to
leave these behind so that I'm not in
bondage to them he says the superior
consciousness is is that of not being in
bondage to natural enjoyment of pleasure
so the person denies himself natural
enjoyment and pleasure could be that of
drink could be that of food could be
that sex could be all sorts of things
what he does in this case is he
demonstrates by his actions his contempt
for them is no lie but is genuine he's
not just putting on airs he's not doing
a show he's not just following the rules
and and you could say lots of religious
people you know do that sort of thing
they they are just you know bowing the
social prat
that's fine I'm not talking about that
kind of religious person and the person
of the Enlightenment in taking every
religious person to be of that sort is
doing them a disservice and
misunderstanding them and that's a
problem says similarly enlightenment
finds it foolish the individual absolves
itself of its quality of being
absolutely individual what is its
quality of being absolutely individual
its property its possessions its eigen
tongue you know that which it has for
itself he says it gives up its property
well what does it do when it gives up
its property say you know deeding
something to a monastery or you know
sacrificing the wealth that it has or
the opportunities for gaining wealth by
ill-gotten ways by following the the
rules you know not charging exorbitant
interest when when they could he says by
doing that it shows in truth it's not in
earnest with this isolation of itself
but raised above the natural necessity
of isolating itself and in this absolute
isolation of being for self denying that
others are the same as itself by giving
a property Hegel saying the person of
faith is reasserting their connection
with other people in absolute being in
the religious community for example
giving homes you know which may not be
to somebody in the religious community
but incorporates them into a you might
say brotherhood and sisterhood of human
beings so he goes on and he says in
doing this it's it's raised above this
natural necessity pure insight finds
both of these things sacrificing
enjoyment and pleasure sacrificing
property to be of no purpose of no
purpose means not actually tailored to
some end and to be wrong objectively
wrong what the hell are you doing the
person of the Enlightenment could say
how does this play itself out he says
this purpose of showing yourself to be
free well you don't have to give up
anything for that you don't have to make
sacrifices
you already are free what are you doing
starving yourself fasting you know
abstaining from from drink not having
sex with anybody that you can not you
know going after the big promotion not
you know making a ton of money
what are you sacrificing this stuff for
he would say so we'd say the purpose of
showing yourself to be free is not
served by denial in the opposite case it
says the man's a fool who in order to
eat has recourse to actually eating
he says insight finds it wrong to deny
oneself a meal and to give away butter
and eggs not for money nor money for
butter and eggs but simply to give them
away without receiving anything in
return what are you getting from God
when you put something into the
collection plate is it really just is it
really about the warm glow that you get
well then that's just your own
satisfaction or pleasure isn't it now
what we are getting on to something he
says a meal or the possession of things
are an end in itself
and so this insight is actually
betraying the fact that it's actually
got a rather impure intention the
there's a play on words there right
insight is Isaac and intention on zyk so
that's showing itself to be a little bit
duplicitous so he goes down and he says
again it affirms as a pure intention the
necessity of rising above natural
existence so so the end absolute being
freedom human freedom human dignity
these are good ends where it's
criticizing faith is in actually
pursuing these ends in the ways that it
does so he says we should in fact rise
above natural existence we should raise
ourselves above a quiz ative 'no Sabath
the means of existence here's where it
gets really funny
only it finds a foolish and wrong this
elevation should be demonstrated by
deeds in other words he says this pure
insight is actually a deception which
feigns and demands an inner elevation
but then criticizes the people who
actually do that and says it's not good
to do that sort of thing it's telling
itself it's already attained it again
you know we want to think in terms like
what is hey gali and idealism really
about is it enough just to have the idea
of something and say oh you know I've
got the idea of freedom and and that's
good enough I've got the idea of being
this this beautiful soul who rises above
you know filthy lucre and pleasure
seeking or egoism or anything like that
no you actually have to do something you
have to change who you are by making
some sort of commitment maybe not
necessarily the way the religious
believer is but certainly some sort of
action right so he says it's it's it's
you know deceptive and he says it you
know it demands an inner elevation but
declares it's superfluous foolish and
even wrong to be in earnest about it to
put this elevation into actual practice
and demonstrate its truth isn't that a
wonderful way of talking about it there
- if you want to say that you are
actually above a bondage to pleasure you
have to demonstrate the truth of that
demonstrating the truth doesn't mean
like showing to some outside person that
oh you can refrain from screwing around
or you know whatever same thing with
like the food well you know you don't
need to like like it says in the gospel
right when you fast don't you know put
ashes on yourself actually you know
don't tell anybody you are fasting just
don't eat a lot that's what the
religious believer is doing they're not
making a big show of it insite is the
one who's all worked up about that sort
of thing so he goes on and he says pure
insite is arriving at a contradiction
it's didn't
itself both is pure insight because it
denies directly purposive action and as
pure intention because it denies the
intention of proving itself freed from
the ends of a separate individual
existence
this means that insight is arriving at a
pretty bad point in its development
that's a problem so how is it going to
get out of that and what is faith going
to be able to maybe contribute to pure
insight probably not a lot because pure
insight is still in this critical
attitude towards faith
you